voie de l'avenir et pour le
Québec, en tout cas, on n'y voit
beauco
- Au carrefour du parc
industriel de Bécancour,
uve un petit diamant vert.
Le géant français Air Liquide
auguré, il y a moins
d'un an, la première usine dans
le monde à produire à grande
grâce à l'électrolyse de l'eau.
♪ ♪ ♪
PDG, Air Liquide Canada
- Ce qez, là,
en face de vous, c'est l'arrivée
de la puissance électrique.
une électricité renouvelable
et, dorbone.
- Ici, on a l'autre
élément essentiel.
- Ce que vous avez ici,
donc, c'est l'eau.
Alors, l'eau que vous voyez,
est une eau industrielle
ultrapure. On est donc prêts,
dans une deuxième étape,olyseurs
et à séparer, à casser
cette molécule d'eau
avec le courant électrique.
Et les qui
sont dans cet empilement
ont une perméabilité qui est
différentielle à la moléculed'ee
d'hydrogène, ce qui veut dire
que d'un côté de la membrane,
on va garder l'oxygène et,de l'r
l'hydrogène. C'est comme ça
qu'on les sépare.
L'hydrogène va partir
sur ce "rack", c
ce tuyau, et on va l'amener
progressivement au niveau de ce
qu'on appelle le liquéfacteur.
Au fond, hydrogène gaz
dans un frigo, mais en beaucoup
plus froid. On va passer
d'un hydrogène comprimé
à un hydrogène liqué
- Air Liquide produit 8 tonnes
d'hydrogène vert par jour;
ça représente le tiers de
la production, le reste ét
produit avec du gaz naturel.
L'électrolyse coûte 2 à 3 fois
plus cher que le procédé par
hydrocarbure; le prix de vente
est donc aussi plus élevé.
Pour rendre le précieux gaz
attrayant, il faudra
augmenter la production.
- Cette course à la taille,
c'est pas pour la beauté de
faire gros. C'est pour diminuer
les coûts et pour répondre,
également, à une demande
qu'on voit croissante.
- La minière australienne
Fortescue est l'un des géants
industriels de la planète
qui est à la recherche
d'hydrogène vert.
- Of course we've visited
Sept-I
- La région de la Côte-Nord et
ses barrages hydroélectriques
sont dans la mire
de l'entreprise,
explique la présidente
et cheffe de la direction.
'entreprise
est d'avoir son propre site
de production d'ici 3 à 5 ans,
mais le le Québec n'est pas
seul dans la course.
"Nous avons visités 60 pays en
18 mois. On ira vite de l'avanùa
rapidement les autorisations
gouvernementales et l'appui
de la communauté", explique
la femme d'affaires.- On a tous.
Assurons-nous d'avoir
la bonne recette.
- Le feu vert viendra-t-il
du Qué
des ressources naturelles est
convaincu de vouloir se lancer
dans l'aventure de l'hydrogène
vert, ?
Pour le moment la production
est coûteuse et énergivore.
La production d'une tonne
d'hydrogène vert coûte 2400 $
en frais d'électricité.
JONATAN JULIEN, ministre Énergie
et des Ressources naturelles, Qc
- Les coûts sont assez élevés
par rapport à l'électricitéqu'os
si on saute pas aujourd'hui
dans le train, en 2030, quand
il y aura plus de résultats,
il va être trop tard.
- Le gouvernement déposera
sa stratégie chiffrée
à plusieurs milliards
de dollars au printemps.
- On est certains qu'il y a de
l'avenir pour l'hydrogène vert
au Québec, mais on le fera
pas... on viendra pas brader
notre énergie à tout prix.
- La question n'est donc plus
de savoir si le Québec entrera
dans la course à l'hydrogène,
mais à quelles conditions.
Ici Valérie Gam